Now turn to Congresswoman
and Progressive Caucus Chair
Pramila Jayapal,
who has had concerns
about some of the measures
that end up in this bill.
Congressman, thanks so much.
Appreciate it.
Congresswoman, so the specific
legislative language
still being worked on.
President
Biden says this agreement
is a compromise,
which means that everyone gets it.
They want
you just heard
Congressman Johnson say
Democrats didn't
get anything in the deal.
Are you going to support that?
He also said that
he thinks
you're going to vote against it.
How are you going to vote
Well, I don't know yet, Jake,
because I haven't seen the text.
You know,
I'm not a big fan of in principle
or frameworks.
That's always
you know, a problem
if you can't see the exact
legislative text.
And we're all trying
to wade through spend right now.
I think that's certainly what you heard
from my good colleague
on the other side of
the aisle is a lot of spin.
But I think it's going to come down
to what the legislative text is.
I think at the end of the day, though,
the American people have to understand
that we are at the brink of default.
We have we don't have a deal yet.
We're not sure
how many Republican votes
can be produced.
And it is all because Republicans said
that they wanted to cut the deficit.
And let's be clear
that what they got from this was not that
they may have gotten other things.
I'm not happy
with some of the things
I'm hearing about,
but they are not cutting the deficit
and they are not cutting spending.
Because if you think about the fact
that they've agreed to increase Pentagon
spending, Number one,
they've agreed to increase VA spending.
Number two,
and while there are some fiscal
calculations that are being made around
what non-defense
discretionary spending is,
and by the way, for people
that are listening to that,
that's a lot of mumbo jumbo.
That's basic
spending on things like health care,
education, childcare,
all the things you care about
is what Republicans want to cut.
And they even took back $10 billion from
the IRS.
That was
supposed to go to taking on wealthy
tax cheats
in order to make regular Americans
pay for wealthy people.
To be able to continue to get tax breaks.
So I think that you got to ask yourself,
what was all the drama for?
Because they didn't get what they said
they wanted.
We knew that was never
actually what was on the table.
So the deal, as you know,
expands food stamp
work requirements for able
bodied adults under 55
who do not have dependents.
This goes throughout 2030.
This excludes veterans
and those experiencing homelessness.
You have said that your caucus
would not support a bill
with work requirements
that, quote, hurt poor people.
Does this deal do that?
Is this a deal breaker for you?
I don't know because I
haven't seen the language.
And what?
First of all, let me say.
Terrible policy.
Absolutely terrible.
Policy does not reduce spending actually,
by some estimates,
creates
a burden on administrative
spending that is actually worse for,
you know,
for the overall cost of a program
like that.
Number two,
it is about people who are hungry,
people who just need a little bit
of temporary assistance
and we are one of the only countries
in the world.
It's not the only country in the world
that is an industrialized country
that puts any requirements on people
who just want food.
So very bad policy does not save money
and, by the way, does not work.
We've seen reams of data
that show
that when you put these work requirements
in, they're really just administrative
red tape
that prevent the people who need help
from getting help.
What I'm not sure on and what I'm
looking at right now
and I need to see the legislative text
is what it means
in terms of the exemptions
that were put in for veterans, for folks
who are experiencing homelessness,
for people
who are coming out of foster care.
Those are three exemptions
that were included.
And so what are the numbers look like
at the end of the day?
I'm not sure.
However, it is bad policy.
I told the president
that directly
when he called me last week on Wednesday
that this is saying to poor people
and people who are in need,
that we don't trust them.
And the average amount of assistance
for SNAP, for example, is $6 a day Jake.
I mean, we're talking about $6 a day.
And and I think it is really unfortunate
that the president open the door to this.
And while at the end of the day,
perhaps this will
because of the exemptions,
perhaps it will be okay.
I can't commit to that.
I really don't know.
And our caucus
and it's not just the progressives
across the ideological spectrum,
including problem solvers, by the way.
People feel that this is bad policy.
So so
it's very unfortunate
that it's even made its way
into the discussion.
So but what I'm hearing from you
is that if the exemptions are,
as I described,
which for homeless for veterans,
it's possible
that you're willing
to hold your nose and vote for it
to avoid a default.
And again,
it all depends on what you see
in the tax day.
Nobody should take anything
as cement as cement it is, right?
That's right.
No, I just
don't know,
because the numbers of people
that are affected
are, you know, is is really what this is.
We have to look at that.
And if there is
anyway, I don't
I don't want to get into suppositions
because I just need to see the text.
And that's the other thing.
How is it possible
that we are at a place
where the debt ceiling
and by the way, Jake,
two countries in the world
have a debt ceiling.
The United States
and I think it's Denmark and they do not
they tie it to a percentage of GDP debt,
to a percentage of GDP.
And our net interest payments
have actually are below
what's called 50 years average.
Why didn't Democrats
don't tell us why
we're even in this situation?
Sure.
But like,
you know,
you guys
you guys controlled the House, the Senate
and the White House until until January.
Why didn't you just take care of
this in November or December?
Well, as you
know, that's what I pushed for.
That's what the Progressive Caucus put.
I know. But why the blame?
But why didn't go that was public?
Well, I think it's
because we didn't have 50 votes
in the Senate.
You know,
unfortunately,
we are also governed
by a couple of conservative Democrats
and or independents
in the Senate
who refuse to take the actions
that we need to take.
And that's
I think that's
why we ended up in the situation
we're in.
That's why we need a bigger majority
in the Senate of people
who are actually going
to continue
to do what the country needs
and what our constitutional
obligation is.
Because, listen,
that the debt ceiling
and we've explained this ad nauseum,
but I just think it's important
to say it again,
we go through an appropriations process.
You know this very well, Jake.
We go through an appropriations process.
We argue
that is where the majority in the House
and the Senate
get to
figure out, legislate and negotiate
what is right and legislate exactly.
And at the end of that process,
we come up with something.
We pass it through a budget
we pass appropriations bills.
And the debt
ceiling is essentially about implementing
what Congress has already.
Yeah, no, it's paying for bit
of money already spent that.
Yeah. 100%.
That's right.
And and I think at the end of the day,
this is going to make it
easier, hopefully,
to take the debt
ceiling off the table permanently.
You know, Brendan Boyle,
our ranking member on budget,
has a great bill.
I'm a co-sponsor of that bill
to give the authority
to the Treasury secretary
to be able
to just raise
the debt
ceiling in accordance
with whatever Congress has passed.
So clearly,
all we're saying is Congress
passes this stuff.
It should just be raised automatically
should not allow people
to continue to take us hostage.
Quick question
before you go, Congressman.
Speaker McCarthy,
he briefed House Republicans last night.
House Democrats are
scheduled to be briefed until five p.
M later today.
Have you spoken with Democratic leader
Jeffries or President Biden
since the deal was announced last night?
I have not spoken with
either of them, though.
I have been texting with Leader Jeffries.
However, I did get a lengthy
briefing from a top White House official.
Lael Brainard
called me immediately
when the
when the deal was released last night
to tell me it sounds like
perhaps not
everybody was on the same page
in terms of
when the deal was going to be announced.
And, you know,
I think that
there was supposed to be a final review
so I think it got announced
to Republicans quicker than was expected.
But I did get a briefing.
I still have questions, though.
And at the end of the day,
I don't like frameworks.
I think they are
really problematic in terms
of being able to make a decision.
It's fine to say
we've reached an agreement in principle,
but all of the text matters
and there are so many pieces of this
that we need to look at in terms
of what the spending is exactly like,
because my understanding is
we're essentially held harmless
at 23 levels.
It will,
you know,
it is still not ideal,
but not that different
than what it would be.
I think for me
the big questions are around
what is the what are the changes to NEPA?
I understand they're pretty minor,
but I'd like to see those. Yes.
Then what does this work
requirements piece look like?
So I know you hate it when I do this,
but I'm going to give you a
yes or no question right now.
And the way
yes or no question
it is all the Democrats.
I may or may not answer.
Well, that's fair.
But Democrats watching right now
at the White House,
your friend Hakeem Jeffries, others,
do they still have to worry
about the Progressive Caucus
and whether or not
your caucus will support.
Yes, they do.
Okay.
Congresswoman Jayapal, thank you so much.
Have to worry yes, they have to worry.
Okay. Well, you heard you heard the lady.
Thank you so much, Congresswoman.
Good to see you as always.
Thank you, Jake.